[Music]
we're in the middle of a zombie
apocalypse full-fledged in Seattle you
guys what can you tease I know
absolutely nothing that you can you can
choose nothing but let's try I'll show
we're keeping the White Walkers oh [ __ ]
off
Robbie took what could be a cure for
zombie-ism but then also injected
himself with the virus how long are we
gonna have to wait to find out what his
human versus zombie statuses you will
find out what's happened with Robbie in
the first episode so it's not something
that they try and draw out find out
straight away
when you found out what the deal was
with him what was your reaction oh
that's a question
Jordan is hovering waiting to spoilers I
know I'm not completely up Thomas his
eyes on me how do I answer I was like
I'll give you the face I was like I was
major going to handle the fact that you
guys are like taking over you're really
like military enough right now yeah he's
gonna take it well and he's gonna take
it without a shirt on is the major way
you know half clothes or somehow your
rules are he comes in you know nips out
red hot fighting crime
okay okay well as a former zombie he
kind of should be he's empathetic with
them and also I think that's lives thing
is she is a zombie but she doesn't think
that should be just food for zombies and
it's like affection of kind of extreme
extremists on each side as human they're
to be human cult people who believe that
they want to have like a terrorist
organization I think that gets rid of
zombies and then in the zombie
Department he's also gonna be this group
of people who are like no like my family
where it rains where our superior
species so it's not it I think it's
really it's all about finding the good
med in both groups and the extreme views
in both groups which will be really
interesting